this is game three of a four game series
it's 1-1 through the first two betty is
ready and here we go now the one-two
half-swing went too far struck him out
of the changeup you never know how it
would work out but we do know fetty
strikes him out to start the game it's a
nice start for eric fetty a little
change up in the dirt for strike three
and then kind of an emergency cricket
hack there by the castro trying to put
into play confetti here looking for the
second out here in the first
[Applause]
got him looking change up just staying
high enough diving away two down yeah
two strikeouts on two changeups he won
the battle here then this changeup's
moving more than i remember today look
at that downward movement at 88. cole
calhoun cannot hold up so that battle
goes to eric fetty luke weaver who
dominated the reds at chase field sunday
one hit one walk over seven scoreless
and hit came with one out in the seventh
inning and a eugenio suarez single and
we've documented luke's last outing
against the cincinnati reds had
tremendous fastball command had an
outstanding change-up working in that
ball game train turner leading off he's
two for three in his career against
weaver
and trey turner greets him with a rope
to left well that was a quick there goes
the no hitter and there goes a no hitter
trey turner on a first pitch fastball we
talked about getting the speed on the
bases early leg kick there did you see
him kind of hanging the leg kick for a
second ready to hit big gap left center
delayed steal by turner he caught
everybody by surprise three for three is
the next lead-off man cut the
broadcaster by surprise too hot shuffle
shuffle go
all in a strike
change up to third long throw for
escobar
and a nice play there by pavon smith on
the other end stretches out and makes a
catch on that throw from escobar to end
the first inning one and two the count
gonna miss
94 with sinking action and eric fetty
has three strikeouts already the sound
in yon gomez glove driving through the
target putting hitters away so far his
third strikeout already but now the
batter is nick ahmed the shortstop two
balls two strikes
cutting action for the strikeout ahmed
aware of being pounded on his hands fp
and he could not react there's steven
vogt hitting a buck 82.
swing and a miss on a big hook throw
strikes work fast change speeds eric
fetty doing it all this guy has been in
gwinnett every year since 2013. that's a
great story the count one ball and one
strike
john gomes deep to left
see
you
later first of the year and the 104th of
his big league career one nothing next
governor homer trying to sneak one into
him when you think of john gomez you
think of power to right center field but
he went fastball away and i think that
was a fast ball in yeah i know it's a
caught stealing when you get picked off
and keep running there you go there he
goes
gomes pops up
oh oh what a tag
starlin castro
that ball skipped off the turf and
castro oh
really great with the hands
don't look at his pinky if you're not
look at his pinky it's going the wrong
way well that's the first time tim
lecastro's ever been caught stealing
watch the tag
by starlin castro
on le castro and then the pinky went the
wrong way and they're probably popping
it back into place in the dugout as we
speak right now we'll see if he stays in
the game
calhoun left-handed under the
diamondbacks right fielder three and one
on calhoun
old calhoun got a sinker and hits it
deep to right field cole calhoun
has tied the ball game the first of the
year for coal
way out of here to right field not quite
as far as kyle schwarber's last night
but a no doubter nonetheless pitch up
and out over the plate cole calhoun on
the board in 2021 starlin's having a
good a b here
eight pitches already
that's tough
castro and that one eats up
the second baseman van meter and that's
going to be gap
on the ground for a double
that ball was absolutely
roasted that's a pro at bat folks
fouling off some tough pitches with two
strikes gets to a 3-2 count gets a
change up good hustle by starling lead
off double here in the fourth tie ball
game bottom of the fourth andrew
stevenson
clean base hit right field and the nets
will be on top castro scores stevenson
digging for two 2-1 ball game on
andrew's fourth one batted in the secret
weapon strikes again just looking to get
one airborne here with one out at the
very least
juan soto oh for two
juan soto to deep left peralta back
edge of the track
two runners move up one retreats to
first and the nets lead four to one
on soto rbi number eight spread out
choked up just putting the ball in play
got a fastball away
[Music]
and for a second there i thought he had
his first career grand slam he'll settle
for the sac fly
peralta back to almost the warning track
so nicely done
luke weber is done for the day four runs
given up in four innings of work they're
going to pinch it for him here with
andrew young 2-2
swang and a miss on a fastball up and
away
and for eric fetty his eighth of the day
well he saw max scherzer strike out 10
last night and he said i'm gonna do the
same thing on his way definitely and
that fastball's got some giddy up in the
strike zone still eric fetty's career
high in strikeouts
nine for the first time it's wyatt
matheson who replaced the injured tim lo
castro
right in there
number nine for eric fetty number nine
on the day for eric fetty like carp just
said that ties his career high
a little run back fastball now you get a
base runner and somebody hits one out
and you got a new ball game down three
sixth inning the 3-2 pitch to eduardo
escobar
escobar sends one out to deep center for
robles looking up and that ball is gone
eduardo escobar and it again that's
number six and it's four to two
that's about the same spot he hit it the
other night yeah
a sinker that stays over the middle of
the plate that time eduardo escobar with
his sixth bomb of the season
at the plate
center field long run for pavon smith
and he makes a diving ground
paving smith go get it you're mentioning
bob a lot of room out there in left
center in this ballpark and we've seen
every outfielder have issues with balls
hit to that particular area of the
ballpark slicing away from pavement has
to adjust his route and makes a great
diving catch out there to take extra
bases away from soda you know i have to
say he came up as a first baseman and
it's not like he's never played outfield
before played some at uva and some of
the miners but
you know i think he's been impressive in
the outfield as a defender kyle
schwarber bottom of the seventh 3-2
schwarber left center
and the nats do have three guys with
three hits that one gets behind smith
he got some help from peralta his left
fielder
kyle schwarber has a double and a
three-hit day
starting to enjoy some ho cooking here
at nationals park well poolside homer
was beautiful last night that won a ball
game but this swing's just starting
pretty look at that staying on it going
the other way a little sliceage away
from pavon smith in center field good
effort by the diamondback center fielder
this will give you a real good look at
it a lead off double here in the seventh
and that's been doing a nice job with
situational hitting here today see if
they can keep it up here in the seventh
that ball is gashed out to center
smith had to back up it was hit so hard
schwarber scores easily and then ants
lead five to two castro two for four
today another example
playing the game the right way lead off
double hitting behind the runner great
read by kyle schwarber on second base he
knew that was going to drop he checked
his outfield
and with nobody out he took off like
there was two outs watch schwarber top
of your screen was going to drop
paving running away from the play
you think about suddenly was going to
stop him no
zim looking for his first pinch hit
wonderful to see today's crowd give ryan
a charge he puts a charge into that one
see
you
later
six to two nets
this should be a curtain call i'm gonna
let the fans take it here that easy
is it that easy off the bench
with the home run he's still locked in
folks
ryan zimmerman third career pension home
run
that was cool
breathing room insurance
and now mcgowan a strike away from
finishing this one off everybody on
their feet at nationals park runners
first and second
two
out yeah there it is umpire says that's
a swing ball game over
it was an adventurous afternoon
at nationals park when they won their
second in a row and beat the diamondback
6-2 to clinch at least a split of this
four-game series